[Music]
hi everybody mr. wonderful here and
welcome to another episode of wonderful
on watches one of my favorite topics in
the background are gorgeous aquarium I
love the peace and the harmony of fish
swimming while we talk about beautiful
pieces of watches made by hand in
Switzerland you know here's the thing
about watches and when we get into this
journey together we're both gonna learn
today I argue that watches are actually
not just fashion not just a statement
about who you are and the statement
you're trying to make when you walk into
a room there are a phenomenal investment
so if you've never collected watches
before and you've only started your
watch journey with let's say an
electronic watch which really is just
consumer electronics I'm not saying
Apple watches are bad I have many of
them I wouldn't be caught dead wearing
one of those when I go out you know when
you walk in a room you only have a
chance to make a first impression once
so watches are part of who you are it's
part of your Gupta drama if you know
what I mean
the same as the pocket square or the
pain you carry in your pocket or the
cufflinks you're wearing or the type in
you may choose to use these are all part
of making a statement which I really
enjoy doing I love fashion but let's get
back to watches now here's my argument
let's say you could just snap your
fingers and create your own first watch
collection now how many watches are in a
collection well let's get some Brown was
laid out first watches in my case this
is what I think you may not agree with
me or think I'm crazy but if your
collector you're gonna understand what
I'm about to say a watch has a soul if
you buy a watch you have to wear it you
should wear it at least three days of
every month now people say to me well
how do I keep them all wound if I've got
more than 25 watches and I'm gonna be
putting them on my wrists and taking
them off
do I have to wind each one do I have to
set the date again after it runs out
here's the answer
yes you do that's your bonding
experience with the piece that's your
time together when you're putting it on
one-on-one manoa watch
to speak sounds nuts it's not if you're
a collector that's the whole point so
I'm going to start us off together today
with a collection of just six but these
are the most coveted watches in the
world I'm going to show you six watches
that when put together are the most
desirable collection you can have today
and they're not all the most expensive
watches they're just the hardest to get
and the reason I'm pointing these out
you know collection I like to throw a
little French in there is that when you
acquire these pieces one at a time they
have tremendous aftermarket value so
let's start our journey off on the right
foot we're gonna be working with three
different brands now there are lots of
brands of watches and I'm not saying
these are the only three brands you're
gonna be dealing with but when you start
to talk about the pillar of a collection
you're going to have to have watches
from each of these three number one
Rolex of course it's probably one of the
best-known brands of watches in the
world and there are many pieces within
the Rolex family that are extremely
coveted and not the most expensive we're
gonna learn about that today number two
patek philippe now this is a very
storied Swiss watch company no question
about it they talk about the heritage of
the watches there are certain pieces
within the protect the leaf collection
which are extremely hard to get but very
valuable and really part of anybody's
collection even though it may take time
to get them and lastly I do my peek at
you know AP as its affectionately known
by its fans they have remarkable watches
they probably only make rumored about
40,000 watches a year the Royal Oak is
the most famous of them all so I'll be
looking at that as well so we'll be
looking at these three different brands
let's start with a Rolex your first
watch what should that be well I'm gonna
introduce you today if you don't know it
already
- they steal white face Daytona this is
a legendary watch why because it's sold
in auction as a vintage piece for the
highest amount in the history Paul
Newman's steal white face Daytona with
an inscription from Joan his wife on the
backs
drive safely people assumed it would go
for 1 million they were wrong it
immediately took this mark this brand of
watching to the stratosphere so let's
have a look at the modern-day Rolex
Daytona white-faced
steel all right let me show you what it
looks like it's fun to look at a watch
this way and see it directly up close
now what makes this watch so coveted
I've put a red band on here by the way
this is my own coupe that I'm all it
doesn't come with a red band this is an
aftermarket band I'll talk about in a
moment but it gives it a certain
jeunesse a quoi I'm looking for now when
you put a new band on a watch you're
making a statement you're trying to tie
it to something else you're doing on a
fashion basis but let's go back and look
at this watch the nickname for this
piece in the aftermarket is called the
Panda now why the Panda because of that
black ceramic dial around the front this
is a new addition in recent times to
this watch and it brings forward a
really crisp look to the dial one thing
to know about this particular piece it
is coveted by people all around the
world and not just men women love it too
they often steal these watches from
their boyfriends and wear them and never
give them back that's the notary around
this watch because it's such a perfect
design it's just the right weight just
the right size so many good things about
this watch and it looks great in a
fashion way from really really dressed
down with jeans and a t-shirt all the
way to a tuxedo it's absolutely
beautiful now that's not all that's so
great about this watch let me talk a
little bit about this adaption I've made
with the red band when you modify a
watch and you don't have to do it in
perpetuity you can take the steel and
put it back on later as I do but I like
to shoot television with a red band on
my watches that's what people know me
for when you integrate a new band to a
watch the integration or how it connects
to the case into the class really really
matters let's look at some detail of
this actual integration look at how
perfectly this integration occurs in
other words how it looks like it is
designed to go directly
to the watch's case there's no gap
there's no missing space it's a perfect
integration there are many companies
that make these aftermarket vans but I
only work with what it's called rubber B
it's a Swiss company they're real
sticklers for the integration they work
very hard to make it perfect and so when
you're adding that red band you're
trying to make a statement as an akuna
ball as an addition you want it to be
perfect and that's why I use this
particular brand and they do it for many
different watch styles you can go to
their website rubber B and have a look
at it but for me this is the way it
works now let's get back to the
investment part one of the things to
learn about a coveted watch like this
pinned they tone a steel white face is
that they're very hard to come by it's
part of the whole process of building
your connection you have to sometimes
form a relationship with a dealer
network that's very important because
it's can't buy these watches directly
from Rolex now great dealers at or know
for example has a very large franchise
in Rolex or London jewelers you have to
form a relationship with that dealer and
then put your lists together and say
look over time I'd like to build my
collection and here in the watch as I'm
looking for number one on your hit
parade right now is the Panda why look
at this I'm going to tell you about an
app you can download for free
it's called chrono 24 it lets you put
your watch into the app and then gives
you the mark-to-market price that it
just traded at anywhere in the world so
what did I pay for this panda Rolex
Daytona 13,000 two hundred and thirty
one dollars and ten cents what was the
last trade in the open market as we can
see here from the chrono 24 app twenty
four thousand four hundred and seventy
three dollars that's an 80% appreciation
now we're starting to talk about
investing in watches and that's what
matters
think about it an eighty percent
appreciation that's a big deal that's
why I'm saying you can enjoy watch
collecting and also make great
investment
at the same time that's what building a
collection is all about let's continue
our journey now what's number two in our
top six hit watches well we're going to
go to protect the leap brand now there's
a very very very famous watch designer
and why this man is so important is he
built legendary watches across two
different giant watch franchises he
built for Patek Phillipe oh he designed
watches from Patek and he also did them
for AP and we're gonna learn about one
of those watches in a moment but let's
go to the legendary Patek Phillipe 57
11/1 a Blueface nautilus this beautiful
watch was designed by this designer and
I think you've got to get to know me for
going down your journey his name is
Gerald Charles jente here he is my
friends this man is so legendary because
no one else has built such huge
franchises around design as he has he
was the designer of the Patek Phillipe
5711 Nautilus this watch has become
coveted all around the world and wait
till you see what it's like as an
investment but first let's have a
close-up look at this beauty this is
number two in the hit parade of your
watch collection look at the design
first of the band which is really part
of the statements you're making with
this watch you can see through the back
quartz the actual movement the coveted
protectively 5711 movement and then roll
the drums because they're about to see
the legendary blue face that made this
watch so coveted all around the world
here it comes the thing to know about it
is it's a beautifully balanced watch the
original design is rather remarkable I'm
going to explode it for you to look at
here and you're going to find this
really interesting because when genta
designed it he actually put a hinge to
make it waterproof it's absolutely
gorgeous in that respect and it gives it
its distinct look that people see all
the time on your wrist and I'll tell you
something really interesting about this
watch because yes it's very hard to find
but again when you're building a
collection that's not what you care
about you want
get the pieces even if it takes you
years to get them and it certainly took
me a long time to get my first 57:11 ten
years but it was worth the wait I'll
tell you why let's look at the economics
that's driving this process the purchase
price of this watch is basically thirty
one thousand three hundred and seventy
three dollars and fifty one cents
yes it's a lot but is it a good
investment oh yes my friends what are
these trading for right now in the open
market seventy two thousand two hundred
and ninety five dollars that's a hundred
and twenty three percent appreciation
yet the youkai yay that's what I'm
talking about
so you can build your collection and you
can also at the same time make great
investments remembering these watches
have to be worn
you can't start collecting watches and
never wear them if you do that
the watch basically loses its soul let's
stay in the same realm of what gentle
design because I'm going to take you to
a different mark a different brand now
genta was also the genesis of this
legendary watch now this is Eddie mark
Poquette ap this is the Royal Oak we're
going to have a look at one of gentes
designs from the 70s that has become
coveted all around the world this is the
15 202 jumbo now it's a funny name to
call this watch because it's one of the
thinnest watches ever made by 8 P this
is the Royal Oak jumbo now let's have a
quick look at it because again the band
is so important in terms of the design
of this beautiful blue faced watch just
look at how it shines it becomes part of
the whole experience on your wrist this
watch is really remarkable in the sense
that has a gorgeous balance to it but
that octagonal design the gentle pull
together became the hallmark of the
Royal Oak brand now this watch is again
very difficult to get and I must tell
you an interesting story about this
I was recently travelling long flight
from New York to Dubai it's many many
hours about 16 different you know time
zones I should say 16 hours of flying
but you can see the distinct look
of this watch of the AAP just that
octagonal design and I had it on my
wrist and the fellow across to me said
is that the AAP jumbo I said yes it is
he just looked at it and said how did
you get it and this is what's so much
fun about collecting watches you meet
other people that are into the same
thing you immediately have a connection
and I said well I've been waiting a long
time for this watch he said could I put
it on my wrist I said never that's never
gonna happen
but I'll let you look at it it nearly
brought tears to his eyes and that's
what I love about collecting watches
it's such a beautiful statement it's a
fashion statement in that sense that
let's look at the economics of this
watch now the AP Royal Oak jumbo retails
for about twenty six thousand dollars
okay twenty six thousand eight hundred
ninety two thirteen let's see what it's
worth in the after market are you ready
I just love to see this this is
extraordinary the after market value of
this watch thirty nine thousand seven
hundred and eighty three last trade
that's a forty seven percent increase in
value and of course it's a beautiful
addition to your collection it's the
number three now within the Rolex family
because we're going back to Rolex now
for our number four in our collection
there are four coveted watches they are
not the most expensive Rolexes but they
are the most sought-after by collectors
we're going to meet the GMT to Pepsi now
now the reason it's called a Pepsi is
the ceramic color let me get you back to
look at this watch because what you'll
see here is the Pepsi has become desired
by collectors because of its beauty it's
got a blue and a red ceramic the new
version comes with the Jillian bracelet
I have modified mine to a be a red
because I love that for when I'm
shooting television but the Pepsi is a
GMT and very hard to get but not that
expensive the retail price of this watch
let's look at it in
detail here let's have a close-up of the
Pepsi okay here you go it's just fun to
look at this beautiful dial I think the
red band on this looks absolutely
spectacular no question about it
and when it comes into play and look at
how that face works so beautifully with
that blue and red ceramic dial
absolutely gorgeous but I'll tell you
what's really gorgeous look at the value
in the after market of this watch the
price at retail is 9855 if you go to
your app chrono 24 plug this watch in
its now last trade globally at 18,000
832 that's right kiddies a 91% increase
in value
Oh just a moment that brings a tear to
my eyes so we're building our panic CO
and in each case getting between 40 50
60 70 80 % appreciation if we're willing
to wait and that's the whole point of
this journey you have to realize that
watch collecting is a journey it is not
a destination it's going to take a very
long time to find these pieces but just
like the fish swimming in the tank
behind us you have to be at peace
collecting that's what it's all about
now let's go and stay in the Rolex
family for another collection piece this
one is called the Submariner Hulk it's
also a beautiful watch because it
incorporates the legendary green on
green and a lot of people don't know the
Rolex official color is green the boxes
are green for example once in a while
they'll put a green dial with a green
bezel and that becomes a Hulk that's the
nickname for it I love the Hulk it's an
absolutely gorgeous watch I think it
looks even more beautiful with a red
band on it my incorporation of the
rubber B which I'll be using when I
shoot television I think it's just
spectacular
you know think about this this is
another watch that is not that expensive
but has extraordinary appreciation in
the aftermarket let's have a little look
a little close-up of this beautiful
watch
you know you have to think about the
Rolex in terms of its value as a
collectible but also it's a beautiful
timepiece to be worn have a look at the
Hulk again gorgeous in the sense that
it's part of that Rolex family and the
weight and the look of it is well-known
but when you see the green on green as
you're about to see here you get this
incredible impression of something
unique and new but that's not all that
matters again as part of your collection
you have to think about the desire of
other people towards this watch and what
they do to it in the aftermarket so
let's see what that aftermarket
valuation is are you ready oh my
goodness
remember the green Hulk retails for nine
thousand six hundred and eighty dollars
and ten cents that's what I bought it
for in the after market right now
fifteen thousand four hundred and
seventy dollars that's a sixty percent
appreciation remember these are marked
to market by the day this is the last
purchase price in the aftermarket of
this gorgeous watch another spectacular
piece of your collection number five on
the list and finally and this one is
going to really give you a chill down
your spine these are extremely rare in
fact they have just come on to the
market this year we're now going to be
looking at the legendary Rolex
Batman Dan nnnnnn antenna exactly that's
the nickname this is the Rolex GMT to
legendarily known as the Batman for
obvious reasons you're going to see
right now this watch is just come on the
market in the last few months this is
the new 2019 version with a brand new
movement that stores when it's wound up
to three days off your wrist which is
absolutely spectacular but the look and
I have the original bracelet on it the
Julian bracelet absolutely gorgeous no
question about it now what's so
interesting about this Batman is the
look is striking many feel that it's the
number two desired watch in Rolex after
the white face Daytona because it's
stark beauty it yes it's a sports watch
but look at how crisp that look is how
gorgeous it is on your wrist again
whether you're in jeans or a t-shirt or
you're putting it on with a tuxedo the
bed is also beautiful and you can love
that band for what it is or take it and
modify it with a rubber B as I like to
do the point is when you see the
extraordinary aftermarket and it's
probably because it's so rare right now
look at what this watch is valued for in
the aftermarket and I'll tell you it's
rather extraordinary I'll give it to you
just by the numbers this thing is
amazing because the Rolex Batman retails
for ten thousand and seventy dollars and
94 cents
I waited quite a while for it but the
after market today o could halt as they
say is twenty three thousand one hundred
and four dollars that's a hundred and
twenty-nine percent increase oh now now
you know what I'm talking about here
these watches aren't just beautiful
because they're collectible they're
beautiful because they're fantastic
investments and that's what you should
think about you take a watch like this
panda with this red band put it on your
wrist you're making a statement absolute
statement here and I'll tell you why it
that red band works with my red you know
square pocket and then of course oh my
goodness look at that I'm putting
together a look a feel a statement red
on red on red absolutely gorgeous with a
black crisp suit on a white shirt this
is what I'm talking about
you lift your hand look at the time the
watch shines it becomes part of your
persona you will never see me with a
consumer watch on like an Apple watch
nothing against Apple great company but
I don't want to be a drone walking
around like a robot like everybody else
I want to make a statement I want to be
part of my collection I would never put
an Apple watch it connects you and I'm
not gonna get 129 percent appreciation I
bet you that watch loses 30 percent when
you walk out of the store the watches
I'm talking about here are going to be
your first collection may take you years
to get them but let's have a
let's take them down on the dance floor
again all six of these beautiful watches
all together let's have a look at your
collection are you ready oh the Panda
isn't that beautiful
what's next on the hit parade it's the
Patek Phillipe novelists just gorgeous
no question about it right beside it
designed by jente also that's that ap
Royal Oak beautiful beautiful watch back
to the Rolex family there it is the
Pepsi with the red band and of course
the Hulk
isn't that gorgeous and now finally in
your collection number six the Batman
dananana dananana net and now they go
round and round again this collection on
average has practically doubled in price
and of course that's why I love it so
much what I love about watches is you're
having a fantastic time wearing them but
you're also investing in this platform
of these beautiful watches now many will
debate me and say no those they're those
aren't the first six you should get I'd
love to have that debate with any of you
I love to talk about watches but what
I've just given you here is probably the
most coveted collection in the world
starting with these six you can't go
wrong from the beauty on your wrist to
what they've done in your bank account
as an investment and that's what I'm all
about
I love to marry beauty with returns
that's it for this edition of wonderful
and watches I can't wait to join you
again I've got a really big surprise
coming up in a few weeks of a remarkable
new watch that's just made it on the
market I should be getting it around two
weeks from now and I'll be right back to
you with it when I get it I think it's
gonna be a wonderful investment so for
now goodbye and enjoy your collection
nothing like
just love talking about
[Music]